hello everyone
mr president it is a great honor to
welcome you
and your team to pfizer's kalamazoo
michigan site
established in 1948 our kalamazoo site
is
one of three manufacturing plants in the
u.s
that are engaged in the manufacturing of
the pfizer biontech covenanting vaccine
our colleagues here have been working
around the clock throughout the pandemic
to ensure a continuous supply of
critical hospital medicines
as well of course as to produce and
supervisors covenanting
vaccine from hour one
of this presidency and to be honest well
before the elections
president biden has demonstrated an
understanding
of the urgency of this pandemic
a deep compassion for those who
lives have been impacted and unwavering
believe in the ability of both
science and american ingenuity
to help us bring an end to this public
health crisis
i'm happy to say that the manufacturing
and shipping of the vaccine have gone
very well so far as of february 17th
we have supplied 40 million doses to the
us government and our shipment accuracy
is 99.9
of course recognizing the urgency of
vaccinating
as many americans as quickly as possible
we are taking steps to further
accelerate our production
to this end we have found a great ally
in the biden administration
which has significantly aided our
efforts
in a number of areas including
support for rated orders through the
defense production act
helping securing both critical materials
and
equipment needed here in kalamazoo to
expand our manufacturing capacity
and fulfill the us orders
in addition pfizer has been working to
expand and enhance our manufacturing
capabilities
to increase the number of doses we are
able to produce
globally by the end of 2021
as part of this expansion we are adding
a new formulation suites
here in kalamazoo lipid
production capabilities in both
kalamazoo and
at our site in groton connecticut and
fill finish lines at our site in
mcpherson
kansas in addition we have engaged two
u.s contract manufacturers and we are
also increasing the supply of raw
materials
from existing suppliers and bringing all
new suppliers
we have improved our processes to double
the batch size and increase yield and we
have deployed more efficient lab test
methods
to reduce release times
all of these efforts have allowed us to
reduce our timelines
from approximately 110 days
from start to buy already
and we are now a pro approaching an
average of
60 days which is an almost 50
improvement thanks to all of these
actions but
more importantly thanks to the support
of the biden administration
over the coming few weeks we expect to
increase the number of doses
being shipped from the u.s for the u.s
from an average of five million doses
per week
which is the average until now to more
than double
of that number starting from the next
couple of weeks
we are on track to provide to the u.s
government a total of 120 million doses
by the end of march
and to reach 200 million doses released
by the end of may two months ahead of
the original schedule
of that milestone of course today
during this meeting the president
challenged us to identify additional
ways
in which his administration could help
us potentially accelerate even
further the delivery of the full 300
million doses earlier than july
mr president the challenge is accepted
and we will try
to do our best we are also
very pleased to say that we are
continually looking for ways to improve
accessibility to the vaccine just this
morning
we announced new data demonstrating the
stability
of our covet 19 vaccine when stored for
a total of two weeks at minus 20
degrees celsius the temperature more
commonly found
in pharmaceutical freezers this is in
addition
to the five days of stability at
standard refrigerated temperature
between
two and eight degrees of celsius
if based on this data the fda grants us
an update or license
this new storage option would offer
pharmacists and vaccination centers
greater flexibility
of course all of this work to increase
supply and distribution will mean
nothing
if people are not willing to show up and
roll up their sleeves to be vaccinated
that is why we upload the biden
administration's unwavering focus
and strong's efforts to advance vaccine
confidence
equitable distribution of the vaccine
and overall
health equity looking ahead i'm
confident the collaboration we are
establishing with the vaccine
partnership
will grow even deeper over the next four
years as we work
to achieve more public health
breakthroughs
and this is because president biden
understands the importance of moving
at the speed of science
pfizer's participation for example in
the national
cancer institute's cancer moonshot
initiative
is just one example of our third
commitment
to accelerating the discovery of medical
breakthroughs
pfizer's chief scientific officer the
head of our research organizations
dr michael dolston is a founding member
of cancer moonshot and we all know of
the president's deep
personal involvement his advocacy for
accelerated cancer research
in the wake of his son's boss passing
has made a real impact the same type of
impact our colleagues hope to make every
day
in pursuit of our purpose which is
breakthroughs
that change patients lives
once again mr president i want to thank
you for visiting our kalamazoo
mexican side and for all your support
and now ladies and gentlemen it is my
great honor to introduce
the president of the united states
thank you very much thank you not only
what you do
for the the uh
credit you've given me that i really
don't deserve
this is uh this is a case
of life and death
we're talking about uh
people's lives i wanted i want you to
know that
once we beat the covid we're going to do
everything we can to end cancer as we
know it
i've asked dr eric lander a renowned
harvard mit scientist
to co-lead the presidential council of
advisors in science and technology
and the office of science and technology
policy
these are white house offices that bring
together the country's top scientists
and addressed our most pressing needs
they'll be part of the administration's
work to develop a
darpa-like advanced research effort on
cancer
and other diseases just like there is
darpa
and the defense department that develops
the breakthroughs to protect our country
this administration is going to be
guided by science
to save lives and to make lives better
that's why i wanted to come here albert
thank you
and thank all the workers here in
kalamazoo
i'm here to thank my good friend
governor whitmer and she has become a
good and close friend
governor's been on the front lines of
this pandemic as well for a long time
and i think she's doing an incredible
job in a very difficult circumstances
and michigan is also fortunate to have
my buddy gary peters as united states
senator and
debbie stabenow gary is here gary has
been a workhorse in making sure
that we move through this funding to get
things done
because he understands better than
anyone it's about urgency
the urgency of the moment so gary thank
you senator
thank you for all you're doing last week
i
i toured the vaccine research center for
national institute of health
in bethesda maryland i met world-class
doctors scientists and researchers who
were
critical for discovering the vaccines in
record time
i remember when we first started talking
about this asking dr fauci and others
said well
it could take up to several years maybe
as many as six or eight years
to find find in a vaccine
it's a miracle of science and the
brilliant minds
that we have around us and now it's a
second miracle
the miracle of manufacturing to produce
hundreds of millions of doses let me say
that again
hundreds of millions of doses
i came here because i want the american
people to understand the extraordinary
extraordinary work that's being done to
undertake the most difficult
operational challenges this nation has
ever faced
and let me say parenthetically that it's
not enough
that we find cures for americans there
needs to be
cures that the world is able to take
part of because you can't build a wall
or fence high enough to keep a pandemic
out
on our tour i met a few of your nearly 3
000 workers albert
experts managing ingredients that come
in from different cities and states
experts handling 3d modeling and
artificial intelligence
to ensure that every dose is properly
crafted
experts ensuring environmental
environments so that
each vial each and every one is safe and
free of contaminants
all this is followed by extensive safety
and quality control
then care packaging and labeling we walk
by a freezer farm then
and that then keeps those doses viable
so they can be shipped this is an
incredibly complex process
and at every stop safety is the utmost
priority
the whole process takes teamwork
precision
and round-the-clock focus machinist
operating some of the most advanced
equipment in the world
working side by side with chemists
biologists pioneering
technologies that less than a year ago
were a little more than
theories and aspirations takes a
partnership
in our view between the federal
government and all the companies and
universities contributing
to the vaccine effort just over four
weeks ago
america had no real plan to vaccinate
most of the country
my predecessor as my mother would say
god love him fail to order enough
vaccines
failed to mobilize the effort to
administer the shots
failed to set up vaccine centers that
changed the moment we took office
i directed jeff science mykova 19
response coordinator
to lead my administration's work with
the vaccine manufacturers
to buy more vaccines and to speed up
delivery
albert referenced it earlier and i want
to thank him for making it happen
because we work together we're now on
track to have enough vaccine supply for
all americans by the end of july that
doesn't mean it'll be in all
americans arms but enough vaccine will
be available
by that time these orders allow
facilities like this one to plan ahead
accelerate the production schedules
here's what else we did
when we discovered that vaccine
manufacturers weren't being prioritized
when it came to scrutinizing
and securing supplies they needed we
fixed that problem and got them what
they needed
we also used the defense production act
to speed up the supply chain
for quick for key equipment like fill
pumps and filters
which has already helped increase
vaccine production
in fact on our tier on our tour today
they showed me a critical piece of
machinery
they didn't have before now they do and
it's allowing them to ramp up production
and as we increase supply we're carrying
out a clear plan to get
shots into the arms of 300 million
americans or more
and i know people want confidence that
it's safe
well i just toured and it's
where it's being made it takes more time
to do the check for safety than it does
actually to make the vaccine
that's how fastidious they are and
listen to dr
fauci dr fauci assured me that covenant
bacteria vaccines were safe
that's why several weeks ago i went
through the rigorous scientific review
that's why i took my vaccine shot
publicly
to demonstrate to the american people
that i know and believe it's safe
that's why vice president harris also
received her shot publicly
we all know there's some histories or
some hesitancy
about taking this vaccine we all know
there's history in this country of
having subjected
certain communities to terrible medical
abuses in the past
but if there's one message to cut
through to everyone in this country is
this
the vaccines are safe please
for yourself your family your community
this country
take the vaccine when it's your turn and
available
that's how to beat this pandemic we're
making progress
we deployed more vaccinators the people
to put the vaccine
in your arm we're now making it possible
for retired doctors and nurses
to come back and under law administer
these shots we've put new vaccinators in
the field
these include over 800 medical personnel
from our
commissioned corps at the department of
health and human services
and personnel from the federal emergency
management agency fema
defense department national guard we're
literally lined up and
we're lining up thousands of vaccinators
because it's one thing to have the
vaccine that's very different to get it
in someone's arms
we're also creating more places for
people to get vaccinated
we've provided three billion dollars to
states territories and tribes
which creates hundreds of new
vaccination centers to ramp up exa and
ramp up the existing ones
that now that are there right here in
michigan with governor whitmer
fema has provided tens of millions of
dollars to bolster the state's community
vaccination centers
from the national guard at the expo
center here in kalamazoo
to the t to excuse me the tcf center in
detroit
to parking lots and churches across the
state
we've worked with governors in
california texas new york
more to come to stand up massive mass
vaccine sites and stadiums
that'll be open 24 7 in arenas and
community centers
it's an effort that's on top of the
federal government covering the full
cost
for the state's use of their national
guards for pandemic efforts
and you suggested i do that a while ago
and i promised you i'd do it and we did
it
we also started shipping vaccines
directly to thousands of local
pharmacies across the country
so eligible folks can get the covert 19
shot
like they would a flu shot here in
michigan
that's already more than 220 pharmacies
like rite aid and myers in more than 130
cities in michigan
and that's just the beginning it's only
been four weeks
and for folks who aren't near pharmacy
or mass vaccination centers
we're deploying mobile clinics these are
special vehicles
and pop-up clinics that meet folks where
they live
folks who don't have access to
transportation to get the shots
we're also supplying vaccines to
community health
centers federal community health center
to reach those who are
hit the hardest block latinos
native americans and rural communities
which have higher rates of covet
infections and deaths than
any other group here in michigan we're
already partnering with community health
centers
serving more than 300 000
patients in 11 cities across the state
that's because you guys have pointed out
where they were
why it was so important and how we'd get
to as gary talks about get to the people
most in need and the people most dying
from
covet it's important to ensure
everyone is treated equally and those
hardest hit
get the care they deserve we're now at a
point
we've seen the average daily number of
people vaccinated nearly double
from the week before i took office to
about
1.7 million average per day
getting a shot ron tractor surpass
my commitment you may remember when i
said
in my first hundred days just before i
was inaugurated
which seemed like a hundred days anyway
first hundred days before i was
inaugurated
that we'd administer 100 million shots
in my first 100 days
but on the path to do we're averaging
1.7 million a day
soon we'll be at 50 million and i'm
confident we'll exceed
the number but that's just the floor
we have to keep going but despite the
progress we're still in the teeth of a
pandemic
new strains are emerging in a few days
will cross
500 000 americans who have died
from covet 19. 500 000.
that is almost 70 000 more
than all the americans who died in world
war
ii over a four-year period
all the sorrow all the heartache all the
pain
while we wait for everyone to get
vaccinated
we still need you to wash your hands
stay socially distanced
and mask up to help save lives
that's why with the authority i have as
president
i signed an executive order the only
authority i have to require this
to require masking on all federal
property
all modes of traffic like planes trains
and buses
we've been calling on governors and
mayors and local officials republicans
and democrats
institute mass mandates within their
jurisdictions
just like governor whitmer has done here
in michigan
look i know it's inconvenient
but you're making the difference when
you do it everything we do matters
we need everyone to do their part for
themselves for their loved ones and yes
for your country it's a patriotic duty
we need congress to pass my american
rescue plan
that deals with the immediate crisis the
urgency
now critics say my plan is too big
that it costs 1.9 trillion dollars so
that's too much
let me ask them what would they have me
cut
what would they have me leave out should
we not invest
20 billion dollars to vaccinate the
nation
should we not invest 290 million dollars
to extend unemployment insurance
for the 11 million americans
who are unemployed so they can get by
while they get back to work should we
not invest 50 billion
help small businesses stay open when
tens of thousands have had to close
permanently
should we not invest and by the way they
make up half the employment in america
should we not invest 130 million dollars
to help schools across the nation
open safely right now
24 million adults 11 million children
don't have enough food to eat
and unless you think i'm exaggerating
think of those scenes you've seen on the
television
with cars lined up which seemed like
miles
to wait to have someone put a box of
food
in their trunk people will never ever
ever ever ever
ever thought they would need help
and through no fault of their own during
that circumstance
if we don't pass the american rescue
plan 40 million americans will
lose nutritional assistance through a
program we call snap the old food stamp
program
do we not invest three million dollars
three billion dollars to keep
families from going hungry one in five
americans are behind in their rent
one in ten are behind on their mortgages
how many people do you know
that will go to bed tonight staring into
the ceiling and saying god what is going
to happen
if i don't get my job if i don't have my
unemployment check
what's happened to me i'm losing my
health insurance
what do i do this is the united states
of america for god's sake
we invest in people who are in need
do we not invest 35 billion to help
people keep a roof over their heads
i could go on but you get the point i'm
grateful that the senate and the house
are moving quickly
and i'm prepared to hear their ideas how
to make the package better
and make it cheaper i'm open to that
we have to make clear who is helped and
who is hurt
my hope is the republicans in congress
listen to their constituents
according to the polls there is
overwhelming bipartisan support
the vast majority of the american people
more than 70 percent
of the american people with all the
polls you all conduct
including the majority of republicans
want us to act
and act big and quickly and support the
plan
major economists left right and center
say we should focus on smart investments
we can make now
in jobs and our people to prevent
long-term economic damage to our nation
and to strengthen the economic
competitiveness going forward
in fact an analysis by the wall street
firm moody's estimates
that if we pass my american rescue plan
the economy will create
seven million jobs this year
this year we've also been in constant
contact with mayors and governors
county officials members of congress
both parties
both parties i've met with them in my
office i've met with them in
on the on the internet on zooming on
with them
both parties in every state and guess
what
they agree we have to act now i got a
letter from more than 400 mayors
from big cities and small towns they
understand we're not going to get our
economy back in shape
and the millions of people back to work
until we beat this virus
that's why the american rescue plan puts
160 million
billion dollars into more testing and
tracing
manufacturing and distribution and
setting up vaccination
sites everything is needed to get
vaccines
in the people's arms which is the most
difficult logistical effort the united
states has undertaken in peacetime
it includes 4 billion for new
manufacturing plants
so we're ready to manufacture vaccines
in the future
we don't have to wait i'm going to close
with what i said before i'll always be
straight with you
i said in my dog i'll be give it to you
straight from the shoulder as roosevelt
said
because the american people can take the
truth they can handle anything
i can't give you a date when this crisis
will end
but i can't tell you we're doing
everything
possible to have that day come sooner
rather than later
and all of you here are doing some of
the most important work in this facility
right here that can be done
and i know this is personal i walked in
today and i won't say who came up to me
but
one of the people in this building came
up to me and said
my father-in-law is dying from covert
i said can i call he said no he couldn't
take a call
he's just keeping his prayers please
how many of you know somebody
who's in real trouble or has passed
how many people do you know who sat down
to breakfast this morning and looked at
an empty chair
across the table
you've seen the devastation of this
virus in your family
your community but you're still not
you're saving lives here lies in your
loved ones
your neighbors your fellow americans
you're showing how this town this state
this country takes care of our own
leave nobody behind we can do anything
when we do it together i believe we're
on the road
i promise you i know we'll run into
bumps it's not going to be easy here to
the end
but we're going to beat this we're going
to beat this
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
now thank you and your people for all
you do
thank you
[Applause]
well i gotta do it do a little bit of
the math getting the vaccine and having
it available
is not the same as putting in someone's
arms this is going to be
a continuous rolling effort
so we'll have had we will have ordered
much of which would have been
distributed over 600 million doses by
the end of july july
29th is the expected date that could
change
look what's happening with the weather
now for example it's slowing up the
distribution
right now but i believe
we'll be approaching normalcy
by the end of this year and god willing
this christmas will be different than
last
but i can't make that commitment to you
there are other strains of the virus
we don't know what could happen in terms
of production rates
things can change but we're doing
everything the science has indicated we
should do
and people are stepping up to get
everything done
that has to be done we're going to have
debates about whether or not
for example i can't sit nationally
who gets in line when and first
that's a decision the states make i can
recommend
i can say what i've said like i'm the
guy that said we should lower to 65
years of age
i think 35 states have done that or more
i think that for example i think it's
critically important to get our kids
back to school
i think is really important because of
the psychological damage being done
and the loss of time a kid loses a
semester when they're
in fifth grade it means they're not just
a semester behind they may be a year and
a half behind
all the difficulty you were at that town
meeting i had with a
little girl was worried that you know
her mommy
told her mommy she worried maybe she's
gonna die
so there's a lot i think it's important
we get people back in school
there's a difference for example
according to science now
between kids between the ages of 3
and probably 12 years old
in terms of whether they can absorb and
or communicate the disease
than it is for kids who are 15 16 17 18
years old who congregate more together
it's harder in a high school than it is
in a grammar school
we know certain things are necessary
social distancing
smaller class sizes ventilation
testing and the possibility that staff
whether it's the
staff taking care of the sanitary
conditions in the school
or simply you've heard me say this
before bus drivers
to open the schools we need more buses
and bus drivers we can't put
kids packed in a bus sit next to one
another
so we know the things that have to be
done
the question is the order in which we do
them is going to determine on
what moves the quickest and where the
need is the greatest
obviously we still have to focus on
first responders
our doctors our nurses those delivering
the services
but the reason i bother to bore you with
that detail
is to try to explain to the american
people that this
is a process but we know now the
fundamental basic
elements the fundamental basic elements
are
that before you get the shot and after
if you get the shots
and after social distancing
saves lives wearing masks saves lives
making sure that you wash your hands
with hot water
saves lives this is not hyperbole this
is not a political statement
it's a reality the science has
demonstrated that
we also know that it's one thing to have
a vaccine available
the problem was how you get into
people's arms and not enough people to
vaccinate
all the great hospitals in this state
and in my state
they can line up and give people but
they can't possibly handle the volume
that is needed so what do you do you get
more people
qualified to give vaccinations
the quicker you can open up places and
people can come up and demonstrate
they're
they're they're on the on the pecking
order they're ready for their shot and
they're
qualified keeping places open 24
7 makes a lot of sense but you need
people to do it
so we all know the basic things that
have to happen
now we also know that there are
things that intervene things happen
whether people get ill people get
confused there's a lot of people who
don't
aren't able you know i uh you've heard
me say before
you know my little granddaughter can use
that cell phone or hers to do more in
about 12 seconds and i
can do it in an hour but a lot of people
aren't able to a lot of people who need
the help they say well get online or
they don't have a means to get online
they might not have you know the the
ability to get on
and they may not know how to do it talk
about everybody is you know
most people are within five miles of a
pharmacy
well if you're living alone and you're a
68 year old woman
and you're in a minority neighborhood
and there's no bus
service you might as well be 500 miles
away
that's why we're leaning out and gary
you talked to me about it getting mobile
vans to go out
so we know the kinds of things that have
to be done but there has never
ever ever been a logistical challenge
as consequences as consequential we're
trying to do but we're getting it done
and as my mom would say with the grace
of god and the good will of neighbors
we're going to save a lot of lives thank
you very much
you